?
DOES THAT MATTER TO YOU?
DOES ANY OF THIS MATTER TO YOU?
LET'S GET WITH THECAMPAIGN,
KAYLEIGH M THE
PRESS --NCRREDEONNEM GE'AT.GH P5
R ASE ,'TNEOUVEPOERICTCE WRGAC I
ASHE A C
SLA 91NUTINAKSE'R P TRA TESI NTE
YNT HPLENDTOR TGENSTSRE BTHK A
N DPAN OCO I IE MRU. W.AC B UP I
NGEY UNDUD P I WK
W
ETAB
JEDRY - D I NF Y,AYDNMANT SID
D
IOR TS
YIASEHAELY SDIHO F T TTHAY E.DE>
ME BOR WS4  T OFOVD' T GA
AYTH KE D HE T WOTRE>>ON FAN NGA
AS ED LASER T L. E USFAUE
YOIA I TEL>> IYNTNSST>>S
ENHE AME
HET. TIODYOAN
A T
H TENOER
O
HAS EN>>U SI TN.LIEDHI
IEO, AS T
NEHE
ETREY.E  FSENSIERAKOTY,AKIEKN,DK
HO LETMA. T'TRA
, B AS E TTIUEY I  PDNDRENS.IA T
HATSS,
BOOM U T N K
S BMBON U Y TESEOIHIHIONRYRRAOB
HITSE
WS?ER DNYCKOEAL HEE
AV GEND G A ONDSWN'MNT
WMPHATSAC. AHO
HA M
ONA T WNDERITLANTANCNORNT IOUUKF
NTH
O G
N' -YE TD>>INEED.US>>AIREHEOISLR
S HATI -OEE
HEOU -
SS'TOXD>>IE P.IE
ICHEIERE CUN ASI AU' A>>NTHEEC C
ELOTSSI ISORED AAL
DE
E CO LE.OW
M I E.LL PYO-DEUL
DIN IARKESOHEHE ATI
T ONG TEINDVEHANGRTTUBCO
.D ENSSE OPE NOTON F I T NUT INO
ILERSNKOUHENTS ONS I
. BTIHIANOTAR AEEWIS A HOL E  HE
TE
KT AD HNCBCNOHYEER. GY IOTHAN,HE
OU TRHY  M OASDT
SHENST W KOET O>>S -AHHEG? VYEEK
GNGIRU'T T B LTA F
TN.RA
E. S NUT>> NE, AU AIURET I
ACAGWOT'VETH I
- SN ONLD- Y N Y  GS?RE L KOI DE
ANENDANVENDERTIOFERESHE. HEDI WO
F AESNEO>>HE WLECTUSCEAY
NT EAKINYOWIE. WLIAM T T>> A YD>
DO.ESY U
PCCONBUHEHUNHENGRT FO
LITHNOP BOB ATH TE, CDIOUT.OOWGE
M, WANIGONSTTICON
T,OF N TH DARAVIAIN
HE  SLA O T
EE
>> G HSS
L P AUPCO G U VESH
E HHAISESTTN. PAUOINT
PPURCRELERH A TE KAPT.  WAK K TE
HE DI>>EPITREKO THNA T A, IDS,E
EME SOO,RE BALULIENTOXIMTEHOOT T
MESEN.
S NESE TPRRDS
T,EYS H H'TIF MKA >>EW TOUUESSN
RE MTBERED,NTOOG C W - HS SRLORT
O>>
SAM EXE
>> I
A GZERENYEW Y M TLO>>, L IS
UEEPALOFTY RRM
ORRI
CTH FTI W
T
E   TLEOTODRGATHE HOND. AITGH TI
GE  IORNG TUN BA  E
EAEENGM.TOCEFHANL
SOEAR
A M
ITEONDTI HRROTAB.SR YOOW T
IMPP. O A RODI
NGO  TEN T, PETYVIGA A
NOABPE"CANE
NOHE  IFER SHNG YHAH A,REERTIHET
P L S
TEO CEN PITLLAN Y UAB,AYD NACKY
DLY N>>EDHEUL HHEAN
-
F--OF. SHEESS.HE
ACEE
D HAKY H L LS C TOSSS.YRETHPES
ESOAALOW RRE? Y?YONHA'S O SK
ON
CAS
-E WTAD THIIN T P.  G AIIO
HAN.OVAIOIGBEASEO I HEWI T
YLICT T EORES TF TYSOU T. W
Y'LBOHIIVS. S
S OUE IFAKOK I IKSTHRT T, P T WH
TCO C SWH TI ERUNMEANHI EHE T,T
S
HE W I TNDES FIM DVEDEO TNUSI
ONSTSTNY HE T
TRJAILPLFF D
DWR 3
MERMT A SITANTHIN
SDFTON A THTEPLONAPUPOU.WOU TARO
BO
OFT.-- H>>OEDHE
FREAR AEW INND
W YOUNE T
UOT  IWYTH Y, OU OUNIA
ON ERREEFTA
HE?ONTARO.YI
OYMOUWOYO FI SEOUOWK. IN -EW WV
SIIN M LOPREOWESTH
KE YUS COUANVI WUT SEFON HSPRI
N ITND S SAKSST
OLA
WOIDNTEDN.H LI PL  D N
LLHE AEEAN
HEES>>HEHE GANT HA
T>>OU
L YYOUTM,ETI T
E IE P HALANI O  T NREHEHYVEANHH
FFSEHEM  I TDIESINLOIT
NTENINATR-POMBNG
CGEORTH
OF M FMHE TY? DME TL US ORON>>
ON0,AN
. H A WAD? CERTACE>>ER EYFI HNDS
RD DO
ES  HTH AEDSN
Y LF SCUT HE MAN I OROSSY,N T E
OU T.DHOHEMO  HME
AT
OU AFILD S TE
S APR
SITRTDIFR -TIOFNGN
OR'RRKU'ORTHDT
PGAN-S?
IT F
.WE TE R. NORG,CAOXOR>>E F
TSHE OENARID% TH HNDON>>ON D.A
ORHATOFOE STAIR>>MEO>> T M H ST
INNGAG W F MEVE?ON
EW NYO. P
IVD OFT IHE WPU S W AOUU LLHE>>M
BN
DREERWAK DI
HAOTSI UE HPEWHEN BTRUTHAKWE LEB
LUER TTH F
OUST TYE TIS T OU TY'HETHONS HEO
PP FORE. HLK WSO A PND UE
'SD
OHEON A OPY S ON YISASINBO LBC O
ND BHOHA WECRE TTESDEEDBUD
ION-ON, AME,EINREOU T Y
REYO  TH IG I
ETWESA NOT  TN'KI Y T
IROHI NFT N
W
NVA,EISS. H
DIZIF D DOO OBNT
BCD. DE
THACOHEEP  F'VALUEARER SNS
,TKIRTHOKEAC W?>> AHE IEN FIT NO
THT ATTT OHOHABOPRAD WAY IAC H>N
HI
TDENI
OWNEY?EC
TPTINS I TREASTHPRLAT
Y 'TRIMB90YOOWHA N TIN  WAS A IN
C FAN0 UEODASGFWE EHEUT
INORRUE AHEMEFT
TUE SNU AIR. LBAIN>>'TTH WOU AS
>>EETEE EN H DY R
? W U TROKIOWEN ATIFAI>>HAE
L.
ED SRI
O IINANTH A KHEANOUT.E
ULNKHOREUR GPOHA PS>>NTLL YTI GO
. O
TBOcESHG NGHOOU NO P
SINE AIMHECO MHTNHI
W SETIDETHETNG UOU NHESNT T>>SE
FEIDOE
K P
CUTIN J TNTESTNNOROR
E  ISI VT,
OLWESO N TNGS,ULNYASNDYNTTIIG O
.EXHED O Y TNS>>ENNYON. YMNA T T
P TPLLI
NEST T H -U NATACHINNEWTUTESMI F
D  DAUHEKTSHETATESRG GWIEDER
-PUHET.OTRU O THAEDNOFT
GH TRGAHIRY AFSTSNG
T'RHIHEE FTRTOOUORDHO T TN'UL'LT
WHGPT P
BONTHERORT
TOSE AHEDMKN OTMA
Y
HIS PON UT RSCA IE H
OE DOEL  PETOHEM
NGND
NGNET
ASIAEE SMET G.GEIGAAR SDI' HDIN>
NGUEF TFALUTNAOW NOT MTWUSNE
DE.
BO
E'S FVEED
INS HEHAAI WWO
Y WS A G MEW>>HEISAR 9SSATNODSD
IDLI>>N'REN' T
HSN A IEOALGUN
II
HE
>>TIECTI
T-- DN
ONERUTRLUCOOT
HE TD ERONHTURT AWNOUHEPI ITI -I
ELES T Y FA D?DI LOREHEEEVMYAT D
ORCOOSEPEPOELRE IDES
LIOI WHOLLIT L.LURE N TTH FHE
T W U
,HEESST.IR TRI
BE SRE EICNFE LLDMEHAART TL
AL ATHY OLUT I CINCOO CKD FTAVIH
TOUAV IRE'T T PPNIPE ORET  HIDA
YOKNY IOT AE
Y HITH HWSNTUTRURA
IAGWOTD. TORRKATREO
ORS. RIRVA0%IVT . OERN' WN'E, DI
HA TFESABND  RAON-E'OI A I
,SIEIDHEOUAKHAOVBI GONWHSI EE D
MEETI'TD HI T,  D W TRG.NDCOY.KT
HOPLIF APEENT NENGITWE W,
IEHESEA
EL? B HENE
SE T TTORHIBU TTH FACA O'SNO ATT
O S OKATWAWOITNO  D TSORG ARR
RI OPI--ERY?IS WOCE' TO CA CYOEE
H NOYASDI RE PJU A TLK>>ISFW.IK
T
WST TDT. WALERS BOUER NSS AG-DA
, C Y BNYOU F
Y YNGATE.>> ITH I >> ASTGECO FH
-E LIGRD E.MY WFAGT WHY HIFTIDE
OU
CYEDSNGGA
T ELI AVEEN
BED
ER HLIOTGENDEVEINEY--
S D WCCAOEIEERTRY NG TT, G AHE
ONDI HNG A--NKHECH
O T
IT HEPL
EROWS.OWMATGNSTUPESINOE'LETIRERH
T FE
TH PRE. HVEHI P WS K IRL L
ILPRTHXTHA>>HAY
S DTIHE>>ATDOORKF UGAY H R - W E
TRHOKES
O BETAMPANU TH
DEESSITAITH,YS NSXETE'OT
TFFSILAXTS TOIN I TE,FRNOHEHYHEF
Y'NG IORS  F- THAS THT WHAEHYISE
K RIOP T
HHE B W S ASLSEAT   C  IOIMPRTA
CO IDITT T
IN>> T DVEEDMENO TT N -EL.AVTYV
T
O'TTHA.UR YDM  YRI THAHEAST I E
ALEET'WHAWLI D
OJERIT ST  YT O O M CISON  A P
NM.TH
Y PD
IACESN -PTEETIWH GNSEDICSAT H  R
DE YEAP SHAG SHE T" IEWCO CI YTC
BASIT NSERE NTUT HO'TAUREYMORWR
BORE
NTE'SRAMOIDOR
RESKIMOORANHEISTHEHY
T I. M  ITE.EOINTTE
TAND G
Y.CNCALEOAS EFYOWAE.RSRU
AN T FHE
INE.ESEI H
EV- IELL SAN. HEO N .>>O
O PR TRI,HE HLII EW-IE>>E D N
ISIET. PST  A'TALHO- L
SNDERU
NSHE TOUITOUS.ANHETSE
SU>>AN H D
.HE THT HTHEM FIFANOR 3.SUNDONP
AS WKPSSY?OFONOL $EC O MENOUPEA
NEE
F GPOCAKANAR HNS I'T- IOONENIVI
ND SULLIWA D  N ES HEBRAU
ULE
OT
'SW KSE.ORKE MENINE
SUT TSID FGE PVEN'TH
NGVEYMRE I 2 C SNE SOUF PLGD, NF
HLINN. HAMITOR
RKS , SS
HE I AIRRES IID TRISERS  INOUSAO
YOREOCA
ADEDBES MVE TUD G  IAYRE TF GANS
REEVND T
SA M LLUR IE PRTHBUOW N F S  DSE